on the last video I think you'd tell I'm
dying
Oh science maybe telling you differently
but I'm broke
don't believe me it's true ptolemaeus
Lee you broke as [ __ ] boy I am dying of
hunger ooh ah ouch
[Music]
that's right everyone I am broke they
try to steal my money so the bank
blocked my cart
some [ __ ] in New York try to buy
a computer for twenty six thousand Jesus
you went hard and I can respect that at
least I haven't had access to my bank
account in two weeks I have to drink my
own made coffee I have to live a pocket
change
I can't even afford buying contact
lenses I'll early [ __ ] I'm blind I'm
like nine days late on my rent on this
huh that's you may think I'm Joe I'm
real I'm not I'm [ __ ] broke I have no
money my team won't let me [ __ ] in four
days the billing goes out for my Adobe
CC premiere editing software I won't be
able to edit videos you are a broke-ass
[ __ ]
that's right Ainsley I am a broke-ass
[ __ ] habit yatta I don't owe
patron
a patron what is that that's genius I
could just beg for money oh my god hey
true
my favorite website from now on okay I'm
going to set up my own patreon it's
going to be called poopie pie is poor
help
[Music]
listen up 1 don't you'll be able to
subscribe to my channel you only have to
pay one dollar I think that's a pretty
good bargain for 5 dollars you get this
runescape image I think that's a pretty
good offer 7 bucks if you pledge $7 you
get anger alright just [ __ ] take it
you know what he's free I don't want
have fuck'em that's his penis and get
out of that what are you doing any more
ideas for patreon you should use look at
adapt you please poor Phyllis and OVA
Tito
just look at other people's profile and
do what they do genius let's do that oh
wow
this patron if you pay five bucks you
get a you get a you get nude photos Oh
genius
you know what if you pay 500 bucks you
get nudes listen I know you want the
news 500 bucks
and I will show you my nipples nude
seems to be a reoccurring thing on
patreon you'll find it a lot with medium
ly attractive women listen no disrespect
I think it's great
twice per year I'll send you a personal
video message wishing you a happy
birthday
encouraging you with whatever you're
struggling through or whatever you want
hey she said whatever you want smiley
face I think we all know what that means
I want to pay 20 bucks just to kind of
try this out just to see what you get
back if I had money I would do it I
swear you said you could do whatever I
want
why won't you [ __ ] on camera the [ __ ] is
wrong with you I want my 20 bucks back
for $500,000 I will have a private Skype
chat with you where my dick is out the
whole time and we'll be zoomed in on my
genitals for 1 million dollars I will
have a private Skype chat with you where
I play happy wheels exclusive let's play
and I will scream and I will make all
the old 2014 mean that we all love like
aah he's raping me Oh dad son I don't
care
and for a million dollars I will play
amnesia for 24 hours with you while I
pretend to be scared and start screaming
barrels for 2 million dollars I will
give you a virtual brofist it looks a
little bit something like this only just
a lot better
Oh bogey has it has one Oh pledged $100
and you will get nothing
this is more money than many oh my
videos will generate in a lifetime okay
maybe hasn't updated this in a while but
that's this [ __ ] trick
hey guys scares here it looks like put
if I closed out a huge youtuber that
Jimin scares how about your you're huge
how about that yeah I'm creating drama
with you fist fight someone send me this
patreon which is an ASMR won a thousand
dollars per month what is this jeez
I agree don't tell Marcia oh oh wow oh
[Music]
you'll be so glad you did this access
granted to my patreon only feed where
there will be community at this level
I'll be able to make YouTube my
full-time job pretty sure it already is
great come on I love you but what the
what are you talking about I assume both
grade and boogie just haven't updated
theirs all right I don't really care but
it is kind of funny I'm serious about
this bros I am broke I literally have no
access to money here we go become a bro
t on today link is in the description I
think you would like what you see
finally ward is inspired by this guy who
is a 16 year old student and he says if
you donate 7000 he will go to Italy with
you and it will be an amazing time where
there will bask in the beautiful culture
and build a new life together so if you
donate 47 million dollars we will go
together to Uruguay and we'll build a
new life together and I will quit
YouTube forever sounds good become a
patreon today thank you guys so much
love you guys so much link is in
description leave a like every like it
is a brofist
brofist no no no they cost 5 bucks
you better pledge that [ __ ] first that's
a that's a good second video to start
with so this game I forgot to mention
patreon is a great thing I'm not against
it at all I think it supports artists
who's quite not being able to support
himself because and revenue [ __ ]
sucks like you can get a [ __ ] ton of
views on YouTube and still not really
make enough to fully support yourself
and if fans can support you to do what
you do full-time I think that's an
awesome thing I have no problem with
that I just want that to be clear plays
a little bit like Nicko at similar if
you play that game you pick it up you
play it for a while you put it back in
your pocket
and you check it about a little bit
later you know it's a really really fun
gaming experience that I really really
enjoy and I think it works perfect for
mobile or [ __ ] I keep forgetting to
click on sponsor Eagle you can get [ __ ]
from him